you mentioned um your family and how
they're around and they're hanging
around the house
i have two children they're older than
your kids my kids are
uh you know sort of mid-teen age years
your kids are how old uh
our daughter is just about to turn 11.
um and our son is five
okay here's a question i have my kids at
17 and 15 their schoolwork
is way beyond my comprehension now if
it's history i can maybe help them out a
little bit or
english but in math and sciences
i'm humiliated because if first of all
they would never go to me for help
but in no way can i comprehend what
they're studying
is your daughter at that level yet
oh it's i mean she was at that level
three years ago
[Laughter]
does um uh i know that uh
your daughter is she does she like
reading is she a reader
no um she she is not
um yeah
she's not a reader and um i remember
having a conversation with her and she
was like
or and she was telling me she i knew she
didn't like to read and i was explaining
to her
right look the only way to get better at
reading
is to read and
she fired back at me immediately and she
was like well is that why you're so bad
at guitar
because you don't play it
and i said i play
all the time and
it really it it stung me in a way
yeah because uh she wasn't saying it to
be a burn
it sounded like she was just being
honest about your guitar playing
in a way that she it also was one of
those like
left hooks that you just don't see
coming yeah where you go look i'm i'm
trying to help you and
guide you through this as a parent and
she's just like oh yeah
and the response was so natural and
honest
um and so biting and affected me
emotionally and my ego in such a way
um it really it was a tough one for me
to swallow because i'm just learning i
started playing guitar like
two years ago two years if you started
if you've only been doing it for two
years you can't be hard on yourself
i am i am i want to be good so bad
yeah i don't know do you because you
play quite a bit
i'm assuming that you're that you're in
a position where you'll have to play i
think i've seen you have
having to play where where you're with
you know
slash or something or yeah i've had i've
had the opportunity to play with people
uh you know who really
uh who do it for a living that's very
humbling like if i played
the times i've played with like a jack
white or
a beck or you know um you know billy
gibbons or anyone like that
i decide to as much as possible just
stick with rhythm
just stick with rhythm and every now and
then
um if i get it's almost like i can feel
my ego
getting the better of me and then i'll
step out and i'll try a little bit of
lead and quickly remember
i'm a comedian
this is not what i should be doing so
uh yeah i um rhythm just
just stay in the pocket do rhythm and uh
and and try not to i try not to expose
myself
as this hack amateur you know yeah i'll
tell you a horrible story i
my daughter is friendly with um tom
morello's child
oh wow and they go to school together
and
i'm sure you know tom yeah he is one of
the all-time coolest human beings
on earth great guy and an insane
guitarist yeah
and then also one of the greatest guitar
players of all time
so you know our kids are playing
together and they're always in like some
sort of sport and we're on the
sideline watching and i just see him
quite a bit
um and my relationship with him predates
me
learning how to play guitar and so i
picked it up on the show and as soon as
i started really getting into it i
really got into it right and was so
excited
and it seemed tom a couple times and all
of a sudden internally my relationship
to him changed and um
i started looking at him in a much
different way so envious and
and and and aware that the connection
that we had
um was not a real one but
anyway i'm sitting with him one day and
i made a note to myself
mentally never to bring up that i play
guitar
right right or that i'm just starting to
learn and
we're sitting there we're talking we
sort of run out of conversation there's
not
anything left and you know clearly we're
still going to be standing there
and in a real moment of weakness i said
uh
well tom you're never going to believe
this but uh and it just came
but i just started playing guitar
and as soon as as soon as i said it i
knew it was a mistake yeah you're like
i'm a bit of a
just so you know uh you're not the only
guitar you're not the only guitarist in
the room
i play a little as well yeah it was so
bad
yeah so bad and i could he and i he was
so nice about it
but it also was devastating and then
i you know i was like i felt bad for the
rest of the day
i was like beating my really beating
myself up and then
much later i'd say i don't know
a month or so later i see him outside
the school and he's sort of walking
and we're passing each other and in
this moment of greeting he sort of goes
hey man how's the uh guitar
[Laughter]